basically the entire episode is like rue
on the run bones were broken blood was
lost tears were shed and scars are still
healing just how much trauma did the
euphoria cast endure while filming we're
taking a behind the scenes look at some
of the worst injuries this incredible
cast dealt with
number one
the work can seriously hurt months after
she wrapped filming for the second
season of euphoria zendaya is still
tending to scars she got as a result of
filming the intense chase through la in
the fifth episode pounding through the
streets jumping out a window
it was a very tough day i mean i beat
myself up i still have scars on my legs
and got quite a few bruises with all
that action it's no surprise her body
took such a beating
number two
sometimes you gotta work through the
pain my toe got stepped on with intense
drama comes risky filming
during filming and it just exploded
stepped on it by the sounds of it it was
more of a brutal stomp i fractured in
three places yikes just because she'd
been to the emergency room didn't mean
she was going to miss out on any fun
with her cast the actress was right back
to set thanks to the care she got at the
hospital i was high on morphine this
whole situation was a bit of a blur many
people not even knowing who it was that
broke the toe until sydney sweeney let
it slip in an interview alexa don't hate
me
number three
the cameras might not have been rolling
but the onset danger was there barbie
just wanted to go to the bathroom
unfortunately on her way she had a bit
of a stumble and uh our girl wound up
with a pretty serious strain unable to
walk normally and needing help around
the set until she was finally able to
heal
number four
roo is really hitting rock bottom
zendaya mustered up all she could to
film roo's spiral down into her
addiction struggles which was made that
much more exhausting by the fact that
she'd just wrapped filming for dune
it was so intense and scary to tackle
and obviously something that would be
incredibly emotionally taxing but also
physically taxing also i care about rue
and i hate when she's in pain the
emotions and physical anguish are no
joke it's also crossed with her
withdrawing which is extremely
physically painful thanks to a safe and
supportive environment on set the
actress was able to get through it all
number five
like father like son but it's not such a
good thing in this case eric dane and
jacob allordy duked it out hard and both
of them were suffering for their work
since the two actors were so close lordy
trusted that he and dane could rock and
roll and make it sort of as real as
possible because i think it's super
important and he was on board as well i
was bleeding i got a concussion i ended
up throwing up after work it was gnarly
it was really really gnarly the nade
actor still had cuts visible on his arms
when he did a photo shoot for wonderland
luckily the struggle was worth it it was
incredibly grueling but it was so
worthwhile and i definitely couldn't
have done it without eric and sam kind
of walking me through it and helping me
out
number six
when fesco and nate fight they leave it
all on the floor i was inches away from
really hitting them but and during over
eight hours of work without any double
stepping in they were flirting with
danger
they said that it's like made out of
sugar and whatnot so
i don't know the extent of this battle
was massive and hard i was swinging my
fist for like three hours my arm was
sores
man meanwhile jacob allordy was on the
receiving end of that sugar glass bottle
smash
it was just angus and i going nuts on
each other and angus smashing sugar
glass bottles on my head and it was
brutal it was definitely brutal
sounds like it
number seven
you know the one we mean first episode
ruined her mom brutal and vicious improv
turned out to be a heartbreaking moment
and hard as it was to watch the filming
process was even more strenuous
so having to put myself in that kind of
situation and say those things that was
one day when i felt sick i was like i
was going to vomit i was lightheaded not
only did the actors find themselves in
pain the crew suffered as well with
their dp slamming his back into a wall
capturing the heated fight between
zendaya and nika
number eight
filming in the nude and cold the
struggle is real the uncomfortable and
freaky hazing scene sees mckay having a
hard enough time it was a private set
and when they came in the room it was
very intense it lasted for a long time
and was sombre on set to make it all
worse the actual environment made it
trickier it was really cold in there
because i was naked for real luckily he
could keep cozy and comfortable when
those cameras weren't rolling
whether their pain was emotional or
physical all the euphoria actors paid a
serious price working with such intense
content which scene do you think would
have been hardest to film